well it wouldn't be a Super Bowl without
a star-studded halftime show but the NFL
was without a headliner until less than
three weeks ago when maroon 5 was
officially announced there are reports
that Rihanna and cardi B turned down the
high profile gig in a show of solidarity
with Colin Kaepernick the former 49ers
quarterback took a knee during the
national anthem to protest racial
inequality well in his only interview
marine maroon 5 frontman Adam Levine
spoke with Entertainment Tonight co-host
Kevin Frazier about the controversy he's
at the NFL's experience in Atlanta Kevin
good morning good morning bianna you
know usually the halftime headliner
holds a big pre Bowl press conference
but this year the NFL cancelled it
leaing many to speculate that the league
was trying to avoid controversy but Adam
Levine told me that a lot of thought
went into his decision to perform what
would into your decision to play the
Super Bowl halftime show when you look
back on every single Super Bowl halftime
show mm-hmm it's this like insatiable
urge to hate a little bit I'm not in the
right profession if I can't handle a
little bit of controversy we expected it
we'd like to move on from it and speak
through the music
when maroon 5 agreed to perform they
were immediately caught in the crossfire
of the NFL's controversial new anthem
policy requiring players to now stand or
stay in the locker room during the
national anthem a change.org petition
garnered more than 100,000 signatures
asking the band to drop out of the show
did you talk to anybody before you made
the decision maybe
I did I spoke to many people most
importantly though when I silenced all
the noise listen to myself and made my
decision based upon how I felt the
controversy also reportedly made it
difficult to book guest artists the
league eventually announced the man will
share the stage with rappers Big Boi and
Travis Scott as a nod to Atlanta's rich
hip-hop legacy Scott took heat from fans
for signing on but did so only after the
NFL agreed to join him in making a half
million dollar donation to a social
justice organization he's the man right
now and he comes in hot this is the show
that's gonna have the biggest hip-hop
presence that there has ever been on
this on the show mixing irresistible
hooks with funk has translated into two
decades of success for maroon 5
[Music]
the band has sold over 53 million albums
and had nine number-one singles they set
the record for the most chart toppers by
a group in the twenty-year history of
the Billboard Top 40 their latest hit
grammy-nominated girls like you
celebrates powerful women including
activists and entrepreneurs the video is
nearing two billion views online as the
message resonates in the me to error
[Music]
that video was really one of the most
amazing projects I think I've ever been
a part of in my life we love the life
that it gave the song beyond just the
silly pop song you know it's it kind of
gathered a new meaning you know from the
video and it's great to be playing
potentially playing the song at the
Super Bowl with an audience of more than
100 million watching there's a lot of
pressure to get it right we are we're in
Atlanta we're so close to where dr. King
was born and raised what do you say to
the folks who say that they just want to
be heard and how will your performance
speak to that they will be that's all I
want to say because I don't want to
spoil anything I'd like to think that
people know where I stand as a human
being after two decades of doing this
I'm not a speaker I'm not a public
speaker I do speak but it's through the
music
[Music]
Adam told me he doesn't want to be a
politician but he knows that on Sunday
he will have a voice that is speaking to
millions and he wants to make sure that
everyone that is listening they know
that he has also been listening to them
Norah what an important message by Adam
Levine a maroon 5 I'm really glad you
did that interview Kevin thank you so
much thanks Norah